what about deadlines
can we um okay so this is like a therapy
session uh
is uh why it seems like i don't
i only get stuff done that has deadlines
and so the
one of the implied powerful things about
time blocking is there's
a kind of deadline or there's a
artificial a real sense of urgency
do you think it's possible to get
anything done in this world without
deadlines why why do deadlines work so
well
well it's i mean it's a clear
motivational signal but in the
in the short term you do get an effect
like that in time blocking i think the
the strong effect you get by saying
this is the exact time i'm going to work
on this is that you don't have the
debate with yourself every three minutes
about
should i take a break now right like
this is a big issue with just saying you
know i'm going to go right
i'm going to write for a while and
that's it because your mind is saying
well obviously we're going to take some
breaks
right we're not just going to write
forever and so why not right now
you have to be like well not right now
let's go a little bit longer five
minutes later we'll always take a break
now like we should probably look at the
internet
now you have to constantly have this
battle on the other hand if you're in a
time block schedule
like i've got these two hours put aside
for writing that's what i'm supposed to
be doing
i have a break scheduled over here i
don't have to fight with myself
right and maybe at a larger scale
deadlines give you a a similar sort of
effect is i know this is what i'm
supposed to be working on because it's
uh it's due perhaps but what you're
describing is much healthier
sort of giving yourself over you talk
about this in in the new email book
is the process i mean in general you
talk about it all over
is creating a process and then giving
yourself
over to the process the
but then you have to be strict with
yourself yeah
but what are the deadlines you're
talking about it's like with papers like
what's the main type of deadline work
uh also papers definitely but
you know publications like say this this
podcast
uh i have to publish this podcast
next early next week one because your
book is coming out i'd love to
sort of uh support this amazing book but
the other is i have to fly to vegas
on thursday to run 40 miles with david
goggins
and so i want this podcast
this conversation we're doing now to be
out of my life
like i don't want to be in a hotel in
vegas yeah like uh editing the
like freaking out while david goggins is
yelling an hour an hour 43
of your terrifying thing but actually
it's possible that they still
will be doing that you know because
that's not a heart that's a softer
deadline right
but those are sort of the life imposes
these kinds of deadlines yeah
um i'm not so yeah papers are nice
because there's an actual deadline
but i i'm almost referring to like
the pressure that people put on you hey
man
you said you're gonna get this done two
months ago why haven't you gotten it
done
i don't see i don't like that pressure
yeah so maybe we now first i think i
hate it too
we can agree by the way having david
goggins yell at you is probably the
top productivity technique i think we'd
all get a lot more done if he was
yelling
but see i don't like that so i i will
try to get things done early
i like i like having flex i also don't
like the idea of
this has to get done today right like
it's due
at midnight and we've got a lot to do
and it's the night before because then i
get in my head about
what if i get sick or like what if uh
you know what if i
i don't i get a bad night's sleep and i
can't think clearly so i like to have
the flex so i'm all processed and that's
like the philosophical aspect of that
book deep work is that there's something
very human and deep about just wrangling
with the world of ideas i mean aristotle
talked about this if you go back and and
read the ethics
he's trying to understand the meaning of
life and he eventually ends up
ultimately at
the human capacity to contemplate deeply
it's kind of a teleological argument
it's the things that only humans can do
and therefore it must be somehow
connected to our ends and he said
ultimately that's where
that's refound his meaning but you know
he's touching on some sort of intimation
there that's correct that
and so what i try to build my life
around is regularly thinking hard about
stuff that's interesting just like if
you get a fitness habit going
you feel off when you don't do it
i try to get that cognitive habit so
it's like i got it i mean look i have my
bag here somewhere i have my notebook in
it because
i was thinking on the uber ride over i
was like you know i could get some
i'm working on this new proof and it
just so you train yourself you train
yourself to appreciate certain things
and then over time the hope is it
accretes
you